okay so this is the video I'm making for
my patreon drawing one of my patreon
drawings for July when people give at
the fifty dollar mark you have the
opportunity to suggest a drawing that I
will then take on and so this drawing
was suggested by Shane Patton and it's a
drawing of Christ creating the world
it's a mosaic and so it's Christ sitting
on a globe and he's creating the world
it has a very beautiful Byzantine but
also a hint of the Romanesque in there
and so I'm really excited to to take on
especially the clothing as I've said
before in my videos I'm really looking
to explore clothing and the different
types of folds that come together and so
yeah we're gonna have some fun okay so
as I'm starting this already I'm really
enjoying a lot of folds especially but I
also like the total drawing so what I
think I'm gonna do is I'm going to make
two drawings I'm gonna put I'm gonna put
my two drawings as versions of this the
first drawing I'm going to do is going
to be more analytical and so really
trying to understand the structure and
the pattern and the folds and then I
think the second drawing I'm gonna do is
going to be more of a tighter drawing a
smaller drawing and more of a
reproduction of the entire feeling of
the of the image with the huge globe and
with Christ's creating those those two
Globes and I might not sure yet I might
actually make the second drawing and
have some color in there so we'll see
I'm gonna try to get through this so in
this one I'm really cutting the globe
out quite a bit because I want the
figure to be as big as possible and as
detailed as possible
because there's some really wonderful
things happening
so we'll see what happens one of the
things that's happening right now as I'm
drawing this which I find very
interesting is that for some reason as
I'm drawing it I'm really finding the
Gothic and in this Romanesque image it's
as if while I'm drawing it I can see how
the Gothic kind of bifurcated from the
Byzantine and took some of the
Romanesque into certain certain
directions so even as I'm drawing
Christ's face I'm looking at it and I
and I find that it looks even more
gothic than what the original drawing is
so I'm kind of exploring that a little
bit I'm not fighting it so much but it's
very strange and kind of interesting to
see it happen